good afternoon my name is Amy mccreath
and I'm the coordinator of the
technology and culture forum at MIT it's
my great pleasure to welcome you to this
afternoon's forum elections 2004 did the
media fail as you may know this is the
third of a three-part series that the
technology and culture forum has
co-sponsored with mi T's communications
forum and if you were with us in the
fall you know that we had some
tremendous presentations some of which
were a little bit scary in terms of the
information that they gave us about the
trends in how people are getting their
information and the influence that the
media has and the content of the media
as people were preparing for the
elections last fall so today we're doing
sort of a post-mortem we're looking back
and seeing what the effect of the media
was and the role that it played with a
particular I to its effect on our
democratic process and bringing
information to citizens so that they can
make good choices about how they were
going to vote and we're really thrilled
that today we have two tremendous
speakers with us to lead this
conversation terrance smith and Cathie
Jung each of them is going to be
speaking for about 20 minutes and then
we'll have lots of time for conversation
so we hope that you'll be thinking of
questions that you'd like to ask we'll
have plenty of time for that once
they're finished with their
presentations David Thorburn who is the
director of the comparative Media
Studies program at MIT will be the
moderator for that part of our program
this afternoon and once again let me
just say David that it's been a great
pleasure to work on this series with you
when it gets to the time for questions
there are there are two microphones one
on each aisle and if you could come to
the aisle to the microphones and ask
your question into the microphone that
would be a great help as this event is
being audiocast and also videotaped
so let me introduce you to the speakers
for our forum today Terence Smith join
the newshour with jim lair in august of
1998 and he was brought there to
establish and lead the media unit as its
senior producer and correspondent Terri
and his unit are four-time winners of
the arthur c rouse award for media
criticism given by the National Press
Club prior to joining PBS Smith spent 20
years as a national and foreign
correspondent and editor within New York
Times and 13 years with CBS News and as
someone who is a devoted watcher of the
NewsHour I want to personally thank him
for being here and for his good work
thank you Cathie Jung is a columnist for
The Boston Globe as many of you know and
a columnist and contributing editor for
Reason magazine her articles have
appeared in a variety of publications
including the New York Times The
Washington Post and The Wall Street
Journal born in Moscow she's lived in
the United States since 1980 she's the
author of two books growing up in Moscow
memories of a Soviet girlhood and cease
fire why women and men must join forces
to achieve true equality as i mentioned
to kathy in the last few days several
people told me that they noticed that
she'd be with us tonight and they told
me oh I always read her column and a few
of them said sometimes I really disagree
with her and sometimes I really agree
with her but I always read her column
and I think that's actually a sign of
great respect and a good sign that a
journalist is getting people to think
and that people read her even when they
don't agree with her so we're really
glad that you're with us today so now
let me turn the program over to David
Thorburn and thanks again to our
speakers for being with us there are two
minor Corrections one is Henry Jenkins
will be happy to learn that I am NOT the
director of the comparative
studies program but the director but the
director of the MIT communications forum
and and the faculty member in
comparative Media Studies the second
correction more serious and I want to
encourage our speakers to think in these
terms we're going to be talking not just
about the election but about its
aftermath and the coverage of the of the
presidency and the White House and
American politics in the period after
the election as well because when I
invited Terry Smith to come and talk
here his first reaction was oh that's
old news the election we what about
what's happening now and it seemed like
a helpful correction so I hope not only
that the speakers will take up such
matters but that but that you in the
audience will not hesitate to raise
questions about the relation between our
media and our politics as it is being
played out today as well which of you
was going first okay shall I yep okay
good afternoon I came here this
afternoon from Hollywood on the Potomac
that the true entertainment capital of
America and as I as I was in a cab
coming from Logan I heard that Nicholas
Negroponte ease brother John currently
the US ambassador in Baghdad will be
nominated to be the new and first
Director of National Intelligence
director or intelligences are and I John
is an old friend of mine I've known him
for 30 years and I thought to myself hmm
Baghdad may look good after a month or
two of Washington in that job it's a
very interesting selection not not from
the pure intelligence community and and
we'll see first of course how he
Fair's going through approval the
approval process but David taking your
your admonition about the election and
now let's let's talk a little bit about
the election and and and what I see
anyway as the highs and the lows of the
media coverage of what was without
question one of I think one of the most
interesting closely-fought intensively
covered elections of any of our lives
our time it also produced the highest
turnout in two decades so it clearly got
people's attention I thought that among
the highs in the coverage that there was
a lot of good work done most of it in
print not exclusively that work that
profiled the candidates that dissected
their positions and and challenged their
accuracy in their television
advertisements and statements that
pointed up the inconsistencies in their
stump appearances and all in all though
it was actually a great deal of very
good work a lot of it done in the New
York Times The Boston Globe the
Washington Post the predictable
so-called mainstream media including USA
Today and yes I do mean USA Today they
did a lot of very good coverage I think
there was good work done as well on
television front line once again did its
excellent in-depth portraits of the of
the two candidates in the general
election and I think you can learn a lot
by watching those I believe the news
hour where as we say we dare to be dull
we we we looked hard at the candidates
and many of the issues that arose we
developed a fact
check segments on the truth of what they
were saying on the road and add watch
segments about the truth or falsity of
what they were saying on the air in
there paid in their paid commercials I
think there was actually a lot of good
discussion in the great welter of talk
on on the all news cable network see it
it was unfortunately very heavily mixed
with opinion and I think people can be
forgiven if sometimes they find it a
little sort a little hard to sort out
one from the other but in fact there was
a great deal the very interesting
commentary probably the most interesting
coverage and and the most that which was
different in 2004 even from 2000 was the
attention paid and coverage provided on
the internet it came of age in at least
two respects one as a fundraising
vehicle the like of it never seen before
and you know it has created the template
now for campaign fundraising in the
future and maybe beyond campaigns but
just sticking for the moment with the
campaign so it is it it was long
promised as an effective vehicle to do
that it really delivered this time
raising hundreds of millions of dollars
for the campaign mainly food Democrats
and I think you'll see the Republican
Party catch up in a big way you already
did towards the end of the campaign but
I think you'll see it in the in the
coming years pretty dramatically but
more importantly as a source of news and
again of fact checking and
double-checking of what was being said
not only by the candidates by the
campaigns by their surrogates but also
by the mainstream media and that that
too came of age a lot of it came
from established internet websites but a
great deal came from the ever-growing
army of bloggers who who were quick to
get on what they perceived to be
inaccuracies or worse real distortions
in either the coverage or in what was
said the famous case of course was the
unmasking of the faulty documents put on
CBS purporting to describe shortcomings
in the president's National Guard
service back in the early 70s I am told
that the first questions were raised on
a blog 18 minutes into the hour-long
broadcast I don't know about you but
that raises some suspicions in my mind
as to whether or not that blogger was
put up to it or had information in
advance about those documents knew that
the whole thing was coming down that
night on CBS Wednesday 60 minutes
Wednesday it just raises an interesting
question I'd be I'd be fascinated if
anyone has any insights on that it seems
awfully quick to me I took this up with
Walter bender this afternoon he he
sought to persuade me that he too could
have found the problem with the little
th in 18 minutes or less okay well maybe
so I just I raised the question was it
in fact spontaneous or was it not I
don't know the answer in any event I'm
certain that the the internet will and
the bloggers especially will continue to
play an even larger role I think they
they have witness the just recently now
the unmasking of Jeff Gannon aka Jim
Gawker
at in the White House press room a
writer for republican-sponsored websites
who in fact was his main function seemed
to be to throw softball questions up to
the president for him to hit out of the
park in the news conferences and
appearances in the press room I you know
I think that's that's interesting more
poignant in some ways and certainly more
consequential was the the early almost
immediate reaction of the bloggers to
Eason Jordans remarks the CNN president
who spoke at Davos about about the his
suspicions about whether the coalition
forces in Iraq had targeted journalists
they have they killed 12 was it
accidental did he raise the notion that
it was perhaps not entirely accidental
that those journalists got in the
crosshairs of coalition forces an
interesting question he was a he
backtracked from his statement to that
regard while still on the panel when
challenged to document what he was
saying and to explain if it was true why
it wasn't already on CNN he backed off
considerably but great attention was
paid to it in the blogosphere and and
the heat build on East and Jordan
enforced his resignation perhaps among
other things other causes but forced his
resignation just in the last last Friday
so I mean the impact the immediacy the
probing quality was there in the in the
campaign and I think we see it
continuing as a part of media life now
and I expect that to continue as well I
thought there were some real lows in the
coverage there was that whole senseless
distraction about the war in Vietnam not
war in Iraq the war in Vietnam we had to
spend about a month arguing about that
and the respective roles of the two men
to no end nothing new was turned up one
of the unfortunate aspects when the
controversy turns not from the subject
but to the media delivering it let's say
dan Rather and in the case of the
documents is the original question tends
to get lost the original question was
did the president receive preferential
treatment as the privileged son of a
distinguished Texan at the time he
applied for a position in the National
Guard and when he was allowed to exit it
before completing his service that and
the corollary question if those
documents were fake who faked and why
good questions they get totally lost
when the controversy turns on the news
organization delivering the news rather
than the substance itself eason jordan's
question hasn't been addressed what is
the role what was the role of coalition
forces in the death of 12 of 60 plus
journalists who have died in Iraq you
know it is there I in Vietnam I i recall
commanders who felt and would candidly
say that anybody who got between them
their forces their unit and the enemy
was did so at his or her own risk and
was if not a target
not to be worried about so attitudes
differ there are many unanswered
questions about the killing of two
journalists in the Palestine hotel when
a u.s. tank-raised its barrel fired at a
camera position located on an upper
floor and two journalists were killed
well they said they took fire from the
Palestine hotel maybe they did that was
their defense the army looked into it lo
and behold the army found itself
guiltless and I would argue that the
matter has never been seriously examined
or resolved so that's just sort of an
unfortunate fact that when the
controversy turns to the media the
substance gets tends to get lost
certainly the whole nonsense about the
swift boat veterans for truth and their
campaign it was a fiction and yet it was
a fiction that was sustained by talk
radio and talk television without again
anybody examining what were the
substance of the allegations made about
Senator Kerry and his service did they
hold water it went to the allegations
not to the to the substance that's a
that's an unfortunate pattern and it
certainly qualified in my opinion for
for one of the real lows in the campaign
coverage finally there was a there were
some big shortcomings it seemed to me in
the category sort of unanswered
questions and unaddressed topics I don't
think for example that news
organizations have figured out how to
cover the so-called war on terrorism as
a political issue it is of course a
political issue and it certainly was in
the campaign I don't think they've
sorted that out and figured out how to
address it
and separate out what's where the
politics and the news if you like
intersect in that regard I think they
tend to muddle the concept of Homeland
Security and its concerns with this
generic war on terrorism and then mix
erock in in a in a kind of mindless way
and then they shorthand everything and
I'm certainly probably as guilty as
anyone else but in the short handing it
all gets blended in to a fair model in
my view and I think that's I think
that's a huge disservice now it's argued
that that the the news organizations
that the media also missed the whole
moral values issue well I don't think
that's true I don't think they did miss
it they never labeled at that I don't
know what moral values mean in a
political context anyway but it's really
about character and the perception of
character and I think they did address
that in some respects I think there were
many articles many a lot of coverage on
the question of the religious right and
its role in this campaign and previous
campaigns this was not a mystery we knew
it was a growing force and an active
force I recall reporting myself and many
others did about the bush administration
the Bush campaigns vigorous pursuit of
church groups and their and their lists
their email lists and everything
building up a almost unprecedented email
community if you like of over six
million people many of which were drawn
they would just go and get in tireless
from some very large congregations that
might number in the thousands and and
that's that's interesting I think for
the a for those congregations to address
and be as a phenomenon or in an
electoral cycle
quite interesting but it was covered so
I don't I don't quite agree that news
organizations did not perceive the moral
values question as being as important as
it is i'm also not persuaded by the
polls that when somebody comes and asks
you what do you think is most important
and they give you a list of four or five
things and moral values are one of the
which certainly very concerned about
moral values put it right up there if
not at the top right behind it i mean i
I just I really question the whole thing
I wonder wonder how much there was to it
there were other whole subject areas
that were not examined sufficiently that
we're already reading in the headlines
now the president wants or twice
mentioned in the campaign more than once
or twice he mentioned in the campaign a
concept to reform or reorganize Social
Security and to introduce private
accounts sorry personal accounts
apparently private is out the White
House has decreed private suggests
privatization oh no no we mustn't talk
about personal accounts so I'll try to
be better on that it it was part of his
platform but I don't believe it was
examined and and probed in any anywhere
near the depth it is now receiving which
is very interesting we talk about that
later what's happening to that that
concept and that proposal and raise the
question whether we will ever see a bill
I'm not persuaded that we well but neni
event that's one endless talk about Iraq
but not really about foreign policy
wasn't any foreign policy there was Iraq
policy that's what we talked about we
didn't talk about the Middle East peace
process which had by the time of the
election lain dormant and unattended for
so long we didn't talk about the issues
were not raised what about dealing with
China
in the in the new century what about the
big issues in addition to Iraq know Iraq
took all the oxygen out of the
atmosphere and very little else in my
experience was addressed so I think they
all need more scrutiny in the future one
last thing that was really missed and
was so important the the Republican
competence at electioneering I don't
think anybody realized or and certainly
few wrote about how much better at
getting their man elected the
Republicans were it wasn't just Karl
Rove it was far more than that it was a
sophisticated operation in 50 states
more or less and certainly in the
important States the you know the Ohio's
the Pennsylvania's the Florida's etc it
was highly sophisticated exceptionally
well financed and much much better than
anything comparable on the Democratic
side that it should have been possible
to determine that in the course of the
campaign not what rather than to see it
as evident as anything could be when the
when it was over they had delivered and
they had become and have become much
better at the business of American
elections and we can talk about why and
what goes into that but I mean it's true
and that was a Miss story that wasn't
that wasn't covered the other harsh fact
about the coverage is that the truth is
despite the big turnout a great portion
of the public tuned out on except for a
couple of moments the debates which I
think really have become the focus of
our elections and are where the vast
majority of people make up their mind
those those who haven't already made up
their mind and to a lesser degree the
appearances at the conventions those are
reduced to about an hour or two of
coverage so you can't can't place too
much emphasis on that I spent a week
here in Boston we covered it to you know
four hours a night without regard to the
health or interest level of our audience
and and you know I believe actually
people do pay attention at that moment
and they certainly do it at the debates
but beyond that you know again despite
the turnout I'm not sure that the the
vast complex known as the media got
through to the public in any great
detail maybe you can't penetrate it but
I'm not convinced that they did
post-election it seems to me that there
has been a more critical more skeptical
view of the administration and its new
initiatives of the situation in Iraq and
the realities that prevail there this
remains to be seen but I believe that if
you look at the coverage surrounding the
inauguration the State of the Union some
of the proposals that have come out of
that and that the president is pushing I
think more questions are being asked and
that's a very good thing the real test
as we go forward from here is is how
skeptical how probing how questioning
will news organizations and pluggers and
everyone else be if for example the
administration begins to beat the war
drums again on Iran or more likely in my
mind Syria you can hear a little of it
now how many questions are being asked
how what are that what are the tough
questions what are the
what is the goal let's say visa V Syria
is it just to get their troops out of
Lebanon we seem to have discovered that
only a few days ago when Prime Minister
hariri was assassinated you know they've
been there for 40 years and but now we
know now it's an urgent matter let's get
those troops out I I think a lot of
questions have to be asked about what
the real agenda is about the approach to
the support for Hezbollah about all
these issues and they're they're
complicated they're separate from Iraq
they're different and intimately related
to our support for Israel and and so
those are questions that I I would like
to see asked I would like to believe are
being asked and hopefully we won't end
up as the generals always do fighting
the last war thanks very much
thanks
okay well first of all I would like to
thank the forum for inviting me it's a
great pleasure and honor to be here at
MIT I hope everyone can hear me fine
because I have a little bit of a cold
and I just you know if someone has
trouble hearing me just let me know and
I'll try to speak up so the question of
the day is did the media fail and I
guess one question that immediately
arises is did they fail to do what I
suppose there are probably many people
on the right who would say that the
media had an agenda to defeat bush and a
locked carry and in that sense they
certainly failed that that was their
goal and then on the other hand you
would probably find a lot of people on
the Left who would say that the duty of
the media was to uncover the truth about
what the administration was up to and
basically show the people that it was on
their best interest to a lot carry and
certainly they failed in that respect so
probably at least as far as the
mainstream media goes I don't think
anyone is too happy with it at the
moment then you do find a lot of
criticism on both the right and the left
now in my opinion I do think I'm a
little bit more pessimistic
unfortunately the Terrance I think that
there was a failure to cover a lot of
the issues in the election I do think
that it was an interesting campaign but
it was in a way it was interesting
primarily for being at least in my view
the most mean-spirited the most
hysterical campaign in my memory where
maybe it just seems that way after every
election I'm not sure certainly though I
think it's ridiculous that we spent a
lot of time basically des was said
before we fighting the war in Vietnam
I'm not sure it was entirely the fault
of the media because in a way the media
kind of deal with what the the
campaign's give the media and I do think
that in a way the tone was subbed by
john kerry when he did emphasize his
record in Vietnam of the Convention and
basically made that kind of one of his
qualifications for office John Kerry
morning for duty and all of that and you
know predictably there was a response
from people who were you know whether or
not they were formally affiliated with
the Bush campaign they were certainly on
that side of the spectrum who went after
carry on on that account and III think
by the way just I'm not sure that it
really goes to the question of the media
specifically but i think it was really
not very smart to kind of underestimate
you know knowing the full record of you
know John Kerry's very vigorous
criticism of the military after he came
back from Vietnam I think it's kind of
amazing that the Democratic Party
underestimated the extent to which there
would be a backlash among a lot of
veterans so I think you know the fact
that the response to the Swift Boat ads
was so slow and coming i think really
shows a pretty shocking lack of
foresight in preparation I think it's
something that they certainly should
have been ready for and again I think
that is really not so much the fault of
the media as I think it was the fault of
the campaign now i think that the
selection has been very interesting in
the sense that again you know agreeing
agreeing with what said before the we do
live in a new media world in a way it
been changing actually for a while it
certainly was that the new media
landscape was changed by fox news in the
sense that there was this very kind of
ideologically different voice and
certainly a lot of that was found in not
even so much the reporting as in the
talk shows on fox and that of course we
also have the rise of the blogs and you
know it is just interesting how the
landscape is changing so fast I mean how
many people three years ago even knew
what a blog was I mean I remember I'm
not sure when but I remember seeing this
article but i think it was in slight
that was
lined to your blog and my thought was do
what I mean I just did that the word was
just something that I'd never heard
before it sounded kind of weird it
sounded to me at least like some kind of
you know valley girl jargon or something
I mean it kind of sounded like a
combination of blows and blob you know
which is not not a not a commentary on
the blogs at all I actually have the
utmost respect for the blogs but you
know it kind of took a while for me to
get used to the word and I mean I will
one of these days get on to blogging
myself haven't done that yet but I'm
certainly has certainly getting there I
I do occasionally post on the blog of
Reason magazine called hit and run now
the blog's have changed the media
landscape I think for better and worse
basically the good news is that there
are no more gatekeeper is on the bad
news is there are no more gatekeepers
and basically we're looking at kind of
two sides at the same point um I think
in a way I mean that there has been a
lot of very kind of wild-eyed incredibly
optimistic talk about the rise of
citizen journalism and how basically
anyone with a computer can now be a
journalist well you know you do actually
need to know something of you know what
you're right about so it's very fine for
you know every person to be their own
journalist but at the same time it's
going to create a lot more kind of noise
than sunlight unless we actually have
people who bring some qualification to
the to the job and again I did I think
that there are a lot of bloggers who
definitely know what they're doing and
who focus on there you know area of
expertise and I would also want to add
that I think in a way some of the
differences between the blogs and the
traditional media tend to get
exaggerated like for instance even what
I just mentioned the issue of people
writing on in areas where they don't
necessarily know a whole lots of you
know don't let Sarah
I have a lot of expertise on a lot of
people in my field a lot of opinion
columnist often do the same thing and
you know I try to avoid that it's a but
it definitely is a problem in the field
because as an opinion columnist you were
expected to write about a very wide
variety of things and a lot of the time
what people do is kind of rely on
whatever experts they trust the most
then you know they basically select
those and done to select those in an
ideological basis so in that sense I
think the opinion columnist aren't
really that different from the bloggers
now in terms of gatekeeping uh it is
quite true that the bloggers basically
act as each other's fact checkers so
that you know you can certainly argue
that somebody who's spreading outright
lies on blogs is going to be discredited
pretty soon and it is basically going to
get caught um no the problem is you know
that there's this old adage that you
know al I can get halfway around the
world before the truth can get boots on
and I think in a way that can probably
happen even faster and the age of the
internet on the blogs and a lot of the
time I think one problem is that there
there's just no way that people can
really figure out which information to
believe because you have all those
competing information i think that was
definitely the case with the for a long
time with a swift boat that's cuz you
know i have to say you know i have seen
some analysis on blogs on you know non
foaming at the mouth you know reasonable
sounding blogs that certainly made it
sound like there was a good deal of
substance of these charges to some of
them at least and in the absence of
being able to independently verify what
people are talking about again you're
left with a question of who do you
believe and you're left with a question
of you know do you just end up believing
the people that you're more
ideologically in tune with and i think
that kind of leads to i think both that
and
the rise of the talk shows I think leads
to a greater polarization of opinion
which i think is really at a pretty
unprecedented level right now a lot of
people at least in my experience from
people that I correspond with you know
people who send me feedback a lot of
people tend to when they go on the
internet to kind of stay in an
ideological I congenial niche you know
they go to the blogs where they will you
know the board where they're very
unlikely to encounter anything that will
have done their sensibilities
politically they basically spend most of
their time I would say probably about
ninety percent of their internet time
reading stuff that reinforces their
prejudices and I think that's certainly
true for people and both the right and
the left I don't really see a whole lot
of difference in that regard so I think
in that sense III think the blogs can be
something of a problem although again I
think it really only magnifies some of
the tendencies that already exist in the
in the mainstream media the one
interesting observation by the way that
I heard the other day from michael
barone who's a political commentator
with the US News and World Report and
appears in a number of TV programs he
was talking about the role of the blogs
in the election and what he pointed out
was that at least in this election his
opinion was that the blogs damaged the
Democrats in two different ways one of
them was that the left wing blogs tended
to drag the Democratic Party over to the
left because that's where the Democratic
oriented blogs work and this ultimately
in the Barone's view damaged the party's
prospects when it came to a national
election and at the same time the right
wing blogs did a pretty effective job of
discrediting the mainstream media in
certain cases like you know so-called
rather gate Bing
being the most obvious example because I
do think that the the whole incident
were the fake memos you know whatever
the underlying facts of that were
certainly did end up creating the
impression that the mainstream media
were out to get bush because you know it
was it was pretty shocking that CBS went
were those memos went apparently there
were there are some of their own experts
were telling them that there's something
very suspect about them and it was just
the there was certainly a great deal of
your responsibility now i will not
pronounce on whether that was political
bias or just the rush to you know get a
hot story out I certainly do think that
you know the media were pretty tough on
Clinton as well so I don't think that
there's necessarily a kind of a tendency
to go easy on Democratic presidents um
anyways yeah so I don't really know if I
completely agree with Barone's
observation but it it seems to me that
it's pretty it's pretty solid I think
there's a lot to that and again I don't
know what's going to happen on the next
few years with that and you know right
now I think the majority of the blogs
are still right of center we're probably
going to see more blogs kind of on the
left side of the spectrum I don't know
if we're going to see any kind of
movement toward the center because again
right now I think the Tennessee is
toward polarization and and that is
unfortunate now I think the media in a
way are going back to an older model of
being more partisan which i think is
also the in many ways as the European
model of the press in Europe you will
see a pretty clear division where there
are some newspapers that are quite
overtly on the left or on the right and
that and those newspapers are quite
explicitly in competition with each
other politically and ideologically and
that was actually
also the case in the United States I
would say you know until probably about
50 years ago I mean a lot you still see
is see a lot of newspapers which have
were the words Republican and Democrat
and they're in their names they don't
really mean anything today politically
but those newspapers started out as in
some ways kind of party publications
that were reflecting a party line I I
think we're in a way we're going back to
that and kind of away from this ideal of
a kind of quasi Olympian objectivity
that that arose in the 1950s and 60s and
again that's kind of a mixed bag because
in the one hand I actually agree with a
lot of the conservative critique that
the this alleged objectivity often
served as a cover for not even really
conscious liberal bias quote unquote but
a kind of a set of unconscious
assumptions that often went unexamined
and were often taken to be the truth you
know for instance that and you know I'm
actually picking out a position that I
myself a great well you know that the
position that being in support of
abortion rights is you know the
progressive and humanitarian view I mean
I agree with that and but but I do think
that when that becomes a kind of
unconscious assumption of the media and
when that really is reflected in the way
that the media cover the pro-life and
pro-choice movements I think that does
become a problem I mean I think that you
have that as your view your kind of
consciously confronted and done and I'm
kind of deal with it but but yeah I
think that those kind of unconscious
assumptions did influence media coverage
a lot and I think we're probably going
to see kind of more overt politicization
on the one hand and maybe less of this
kind of subtle and unconscious bias on
the other hand on the other you know on
the negative side
I do think that it's it is a good thing
for the media to at least try to strive
toward objectivity and I think that if
the ideal of of objective news coverage
goes completely by the wayside and it's
kind of assumed by everyone that you
kind of inject your political views into
your coverage I think that is going to
be very unfortunate for the media I know
I I want to say a little bit about what
I think in the in the past election have
been some of the kind of labels and
preconceptions that I think we have seen
in the mainstream media I think a lot of
the time what happens is that there was
a certain script and you know then
everything that that happens all of the
news kind of gets tailored to that
script and and then the perceptions of
various stories kind of basically are
squeezed into that one interesting
example i think is the coverage of of
the religion and the church and state
issues and during the campaign we heard
a lot about the rights and President
Bush specifically mixing blurring the
lines between church and state and you
know I again I have a lot of issues with
but I think what's what's interesting is
that we saw a lot of to look a lot of
coverage about the role of religious
groups in the bush campaign and the
recruiting and churches and and so forth
and there was some question raised about
the tax-exempt status of churches that
were essentially being used as a
political platforms but what I found
interesting is that at the same time
there was very little attention being
paid to the role of the you know the
long-standing role of african-american
churches in the Democratic Party and I
remember coming across a story in
without a rally I believe in Los Angeles
that was held in an african-american
church in which the minister said
something along the lines of you know
Kerry Wood John Kerry has been
by God to you know help us defeat bush
and it just seemed really interesting to
me that this kind of rhetoric in the
Democratic Party was getting so little
attention and again the the the the
coverage of these campaign stories was
in a way kind of squeezed into these
stereotypes that you know Republicans
are the ones who next church and state
the same thing I think happened with the
red state blue state labels each time do
I have left by the way okay thanks um
sorry I don't have a watch with me yeah
the red state blue state labels is
actually something that started out in
right after the two thousand election
which I think it was that the first time
that they used the red state blue state
designation or okay because I remember
reading that before that they used to
kind of switch them like sometimes the
Democrats would actually be the the blue
state and the Republicans would be the
red state yeah and I'm sorry other way
around right yeah okay yeah I do think
that they color-coded them before but it
wasn't a question of always using the
same color for the same party so I think
after 2000 they just kind of ran with
that and then we got this this you know
label of blue state red state and what's
the one thing that I find really
infuriating about that is that people
make these assumptions that okay you
know if Bush got the majority of votes
in a particular state you know the whole
state is label or red state and then I'm
basically there's this assumption that
you know everyone in that state is a you
know red state person well you know the
winning a state could mean that you got
you know 50.1 percent of the vote in a
lot of the states that the election was
really pretty close both of both in two
thousand and in 2004 so I think that
thus tenancy of labeling you know
labeling entire regions
as fitting a specific idea logical
pattern i think is very simplistic the
red state blue state designation also i
think seriously underestimates the
extent to which people don't really fall
into a kind of neat ideological package
a lot of people who voted for Bush I
can't remember the exact figure but I
think something like close to forty
percent of Bush voters support abortion
rights I think about a third of Bush
voters support gay marriage a lot of
people i mean i have spoken to people
who are you know pro-gay marriage
bisexual atheists well i mean i've
spoken to one person in that category
who voted for bush and I mean you know
that's but i'm sure you know i'm sure
that there are more i mean i've spoken
to people who um uh well i don't know it
would be interesting to do I to do a
kind of pull on that I mean I've
certainly spoken to a number of atheists
to voted for Bush so you know the I
think that this perception that you know
if you're a bush voter you must be this
you know fundamentalist you know Bible
something anti-gay marriage person i
think is in many cases quite false I
mean you know twenty five percent of
gays voted for Bush I think one one way
in which media I think did fail is to
cover the people the give you no
adequate coverage to people who don't
fit the stereotypes and I think the same
thing by the way can be said on the
other side I'm sure that there are many
church-going socially conservative
people who voted for Kerry for all sorts
of reasons related to foreign policy
related to economic issues I think that
there was and still is I think way way
too much of a tendency to just put
people into these ideological boxes and
not really look at people outside the
box and I think that that is one area
where the media could do a much better
job
yeah I do want to talk a little bit
about the post-election climate okay so
right now the big story is the sort of
media manipulation by the by the white
house with her first we had the story
with Armstrong Williams who's the
conservative columnist who was paid 250
thousand dollars to promote I believe
bushes No Child Left Behind policy and
now of course we have this new story
with Jeff Gannon were a gym guards who
is this person who was apparently I'm
well I think we're still learning the
details of exactly how he got into the
White House press from using a false
name which you know obviously is pretty
bizarre you know in the age of
heightened security that we live in now
I wrote a column today by Maureen Dowd
basically saying that this is extremely
scary and you know the republicans are
basically green or not just stamping
with the freedom of the press but kind
of reinventing the press by you know
creating these you know fo journalists
who are actually kind of mouthpieces for
for the republicans uh no i have to say
that personally this whole thing you
know both the armstrong and said
williams incident and the especially
that you have got an incident strike me
is not so much insidious as just
incredibly stupid I mean okay Armstrong
Williams you paid though okay it's not a
huge amount of money by government
standards but I mean you pay a
substantial sum of money for someone to
promote your policies when they probably
would have done it for free you know the
guy is a probe bush columnist I'm sure
he would have written pretty much you
know eighty percent of the same stuff if
they haven't paid them I mean that that
is just bizarre and then of course we
have this Jeff Gallen person I mean okay
what what it sounds like is that the guy
had a may have had a deal with the white
house where they would call on him to
ask bush softball questions I mean it
wasn't really worth it
I mean if and it couldn't they find
someone who wasn't moonlighting as a as
a stud service person or whatever you
want to call it I mean at the very least
if they wanted to use somebody for for
the person you know for the purpose of
pitching softball questions to Bush you
know they could have found somebody who
wasn't going to you know get embroiled
in a big suck scandal and who didn't
have nude photos of themselves and you
know sexual postures on the internet so
I mean it just again it strikes me as I
mean the this idea that the Republicans
are these you know evil geniuses of
media manipulation I don't really see
any genius there I mean I see something
kind of on the other side of the
spectrum intelligence wise so you know I
think that this is going to be this is
obviously going to be it already is a
huge embarrassment I certainly think
that um the good Jeff Gannon scandal is
something that you know needs to be
needs to be paid more attention to um as
far as just you know quickly wrapping up
again I do want to remind people that as
far as the kind of crossing of lines
between you know journalists and
politicians it has happened before in
the respectable media as well you know
what I mean some of some very respected
journalists like Bill Moyers you know
Chris Matthews suddenly Blumenthal had
previously worked as you the speech
writers or you know consultants or staff
members for various politicians I mean
rehanne records Berg editor The New
Yorker and previously the New Republic I
used to be a speechwriter for Jimmy
corridor so I mean I think again the
crossing of lines between politics and
the media is really not something
entirely new and I think there was a bit
of a double standard there when it comes
to the right but anyway I mean certainly
that I think that's the the Republicans
could have done a better job of it if
they were going to cross those lines so
anyway that's you know just some random
observations on the on the latest
hmm I'd like to thank both our speakers
for staying within their time limits to
allow what is always the highlight of a
communication form events passionate
argumentative but always civil and
respectful interaction with our audience
let me ask those of you who have
questions or comments to come to the two
microphones that are at either on either
side of the aisle and pose your
questions or comments when you Ricky oh
yeah hi a comment in a question comment
for Kathy I mean just to follow up on
your last bit of discussion I think
Maureen douds point was also that she
was denied security clearance after
having been in the White House circle
since the 80s so it wasn't just that
someone was led in with a double name
and is sort of dodging past but the
people that were legitimate reporters in
fact were kicked out of the circle and
that's significant and I think the other
thing agree with the I agree with you on
that and to underscore your left-right
difference in the bios being on their
right in terms of critique just to
continue I think they operate word you
used to describe people like Bill Moyers
etc was the past tense were worth they
were in the employ of political
organization right not at the same time
they were reporters and I think that's
significant the question is for Terrence
and has to do with the question of
agency I was struck a couple of times by
your description that stories seem to
have a life of their own there are ways
in which the you talk to so the paper
was the depressing a certain way was
just following what was happening that
it wasn't in a certain sense setting the
agenda that people would respond to so
that some issues emerge out in front and
stay there longer than perhaps they
ought to the trivial issues were able to
dominate the attention of the press for
weeks on end while significant issues
are kind of underplayed I'm curious as
to where you know it's someone who's in
the business of producing news how does
that happen is it a perception of what
people what the audience wants or is it
as Kathy suggested
something that the politicians
themselves dictate by keeping it in
front and center of their agenda where
is the agency here does the press not
have a leadership role in terms of
setting that agenda for the public they
do pic i believe news organizations do
pick from among the things that are in
front of them and already central in the
campaign so there's a there is a
somewhat of an agenda setting function
but in a case like that just to take the
swift boat veterans for example it was a
news story I'm not arguing that it
wasn't it was brought about by
allegations in paid advertisements
incidentally is very skillfully placed
in only a few inexpensive markets but
picked up widely and replayed repeatedly
by mass news organizations who did the
work for them you can cause a
controversy for you know seven hundred
thousand dollars in a which is pretty
modest by in terms of political
advertising and that's about what they
spent what I was consent what I am
concerned about is that too much time
was spent regurgitating the allegations
what the motivations might be of those
how the kerry campaign was dealing with
it were they too slow to respond what
was the price of that slowness instead
of stopping and trying to analyze the
substance of the charges and do detailed
reporting that was finally done i think
i can recall to excellent long take outs
on that by The Washington Post and The
New York Times both of which found very
little substance to the allegations and
basically found that they did not hold
water but and they walk back the cat
they went through the allegations and
what was the evidence and what were the
Purple Heart citations and so forth and
they tried to construct the record as
best one can 30 years later based on the
available evidence but it took a long
time it took those two news
organizations despite their size and
their staff it took them weeks to get to
the essence of the charges and in the
meantime it was constant fodder on all
news cable networks and certainly on
talk radio and that's where I believe
news organizations fell down that you
can't just keep repeating and
regurgitating the same stuff over and
over again simply because you don't have
the time or the talent or the staff and
the resources to go after the essence of
the charge and establish to the best of
your ability whether it's true or not
and that's the more important function
and too often it gets neglected in favor
of this other which is just talk could I
just think quick comment to that okay
first of all on the question of who were
the media able to sub the agenda I think
this is where you would have many people
basically saying well why should the
media said the agenda you know who
elected the media I think in a way yeah
I think in a way it is the the
candidates who said the agenda and and
in the sweat build case again I do think
that a major share of responsibility
lies with you know the kerry campaign
for not being prepared to deal with
those charges a lot of those people were
people that they had known about for
months you know they didn't really
bother to do their lugged work and the
other side did so I think you know
obviously the media may have been slow
to respond but I think that you know if
the kerry campaign had those materials
you know ready for them and maybe done
some investigative work of their own you
know they could have
I think kind of kept a lot of that in
Chuck so I think again I don't think the
media really bear all of the blame here
over on this side yes may I ask you to
identify yourselves people you this myth
this event of course is being audio and
video recorded and if you identify
yourselves it will be helpful to the
worldwide audience that will see this
eventually yes I'm Linda and I'm support
staff here at MIT and um I just I just
wanted to say I agree with Missy on the
UM the kerry campaign should have
foreseen this with boat um add
controversy but on the other hand it was
my also my experience that the media was
very slow to uncover the details of the
ad Moulton in the beginning um a lot of
the articles in the newspaper outlining
the inconsistencies in the ad were
buried maybe in the fourth of this page
of the paper or if he went to one fact
org um you could get that information
but you wonder how many people you know
would do that so in general I think I
agree that the media was slow take-up
than that um my second comment was on
the red state blue state situation I my
sister is an artist and I have been
talking to her about this some and um
red is a very dominant vibrant color
suggesting you don't power and blue is
more passive and so I wonder whether the
red state blue state is sort of a media
creation in itself and if it hasn't been
alternated in the past perhaps you know
it should be
in the future I do paint I do believe
those alternated in the past but you
know what's really funny as you know in
terms of red being this really positive
color I mean it's not that long ago that
red was basically a synonym for
communists which is which is really
really ironic you know considering that
now it's a sec you know Republican
colors that's certainly what it means to
my generation right it's very and I have
never thought about tea the you know
respective properties of red vs. blue I
Nora really do I know the Argent's my
impression is that it began as a graphic
distinction on television screens on
election night coverage I don't really
remember from 2000 1996 or it doesn't
really matter and it but it became you
know sort of set in stone in two
thousand when the election was so close
and we looked at those maps and we came
and so of course you're right Kathy that
that many of these states are very close
and and that they only become red states
by virtue of a percentage or two but you
know that your complaint there has to be
addressed to the electoral college not
to the depictions of it that's a way our
system works so no I don't know a
problem necessarily with you know the
fact of the state that the entire state
basically you know ill is counted as
going anonymously for Bush but I'm
saying that in terms of media analysis i
think you know we in the media should
know better than to kind of lump
everyone who lives in a you know red
state or blue state together as being
this monolithic mass and i think that is
something that often has happened and a
lot of stereotyping on both sides and
and again i do think that the media
partly perpetuate I I don't disagree at
all it's it's more of this short handing
by about you it's a shorthand reference
4a state carried by president bush in
the recent election and that's all it
really is as to the power or passivity
of the colors I'll defer to you let me
may I encourage the both speakers at the
at the microphones and the speakers at
our table to be succinct we have a lot
of people who want to make comments and
have questions and the more the briefer
we are and the more pointed we are the
more exciting the discussion yes well
here's a brief one identify yourself I'm
JoEllen East and I graduate student in
comparative Media Studies and I suppose
this question is mostly for Terrence
could you contextualize the resignation
of PBS president pat mitchell in the
context of what we're talking about
today yeah let me let me correct the
verb there she's not resigning she's
filling out her term which has another
15 months to go and merely advise the
station managers at a meeting on Tuesday
of this week that she had said this
before that she was going to this her
second term sheet completed and that and
she would not want to continue after
that but there's a bigger issue here
that was raised on the front page of
both the New York Times and The
Washington Post today which is the
changing world in which the public
broadcasting system is operating today
changing in terms of corporate
underwriters who are less willing to
support public broadcasting for a
variety of reasons a changed atmosphere
in which the political perspective of
different broadcasts is being examined
much more critically and finally a sort
of a struggle for for a soul for PBS
what is the role of public broadcasting
in a 200 channel universe where its
cultural and educational roles which
were very important at the beginning
have been at least complimented if not
supplemented by many channels from
discovery to arts and entertainment to
you name them you know they're now a lot
of child history channel etc so I think
the public broadcasting system has a
great deal to offer is very important
should be preserved should receive in my
opinion some financial independence a
trust fund in effect that would separate
it from political considerations but I
think it does need to define itself for
itself better if it's to go forward and
be effective and I certainly hope it
does hi my name is John and I'm retiree
MIT 330 I have a basically bad opinion
about media but I'll just choose one
during the presidential campaign there
was a constant coverage of two
candidates and they're basically each
candidate was very close to each other's
ideas and they repeated those five ideas
over and over and over and I stopped
watching it wrong time before the
elections and why they didn't cover the
third party and fourth and fifth party
candidates if they were cooks people
could decide for themselves that their
cooks but at least some new ideas would
come surface and is there a script is as
a group thing about me there what is it
that they are avoiding other candidates
like a turd a rail electric Guardian on
I have should be briefing you pick it up
Cathy I news organizations have an
additional obligation though they have
they know there's a limited amount
time and attention the public is willing
to pay and so they have to focus it
where they believe it matters most and I
and there was some coverage of Ralph
Nader and other and the other candidates
but not much your your point is is very
well taken you you just it's a balancing
act how much are you going to give to
candidates that can introduce new ideas
into the debate if they do and can add
to the total that way but who are not
going to win and you can't divorce
yourself from the political reality of
what's going to happen and therefore I
think you have to cover them but you but
you also have to know that you have
limited time and attention and husband
it carefully I think once again the
issue is not so much with the media as I
think with the political structure in
the United States we do have basically a
two-party system the political system
was really built in such a way that it's
very very difficult for a well I would
say you know pretty much impossible for
a third party candidate to be elected I
mean you know Ross Perot was the one who
came closest to actually you know
getting a respectable number of those
but even he didn't come anywhere close
to winning I think there's so yeah I
certainly agree with what Terrence said
about there being limited time you know
third-party candidates are generally not
included in the debates although I
suppose that is partly the media's
responsibility since the media organized
it abates but there you really do get
into the question of you know if you
open up that update to third-party
candidates how many people are going to
have up there on the podium and you know
is there some kind of minimal I think it
really does get them to the question of
time and immediate resources actually
you know the Commission on presidential
debates is the one that sets the
the threat okay of you have to have a
certain percentage in the right
companion yalls to be included it's not
the meeting its commission right okay so
yeah just kind of further prove my point
I think the media really again in a way
kind of follow the agenda that a sub by
the by the politicians Amy mccreath
technology and culture form so my
earliest memories when I was growing up
our of the Watergate hearings and I'm
part of a generation that's very cynical
about government takes a lot to get us
to trust when it comes to political life
in the country and the students that I
work with here at MIT seem to have the
same degree of cynicism about the media
a lot of the students that I talked with
this fall and the students that I work
with still simply don't get news from
the mainstream media they watch Jon
Stewart they go to the BBC or they go to
alternative media sites some of them
religious some of them secular but you
know not any of the sort of corporately
owned media sites nor do they go to PBS
very often or NPR and so this concerns
me quite a bit in terms of the future of
democracy and people's knowledge about
what's happening in politics and making
good decisions voters a lot of the
students that I talk to to sort of tuned
out pretty early in the election process
because they felt like they were sort of
being manipulated being sold on things
when they turn to to mainstream media so
I'm just wondering if you could comment
on that and what you would say to those
students to sort of get them to reengage
and what the media might do to to
restore the faith of younger citizens
and and to get them back as readers and
its listeners
that's a really good question I think
you know one way to I think we engage
the younger generation is probably for
the media for the mainstream media to
kind of get into some of the areas where
the new media have been kind of rising
like you know I think that we should see
probably you know more blogging by
mainstream media people I think one of
the one of the issues the in addition to
just this perception of the you know
manipulation and kind of general
alienation I think one issue is kind of
speed of news I think the younger
generation generally is used to kind of
everything happening at really high
speed and I think you know that is part
of I think they peel logging this kind
of instant instant news other than that
I mean I think greater diversity of
voices in the media certainly would be
would help and I'm talking about you
know not just diversity of you know
gender ethnicity etc but diversity of
viewpoints I think that would certainly
help because I think part of the problem
is this perception that you're getting
this kind of monolithic mainstream you
know kind of liberal suntrust fairly
bland you know set of opinions and and
you know this is maybe where I was
talking before about this kind of
tension between partisanship and
objectivity I mean I think younger
people probably you know more so than
the you know previous generations are
very skeptical of this kind of you know
attitude of this olympian objectivity
where the journalist is just this you
know supposedly completely neutral
observer just you know reporting the
facts and not injecting their opinion I
think a lot of the younger generation
kind of has trouble believing that you
know people can really keep their
opinions out of out of journalism so
maybe the the answer is not so much to
have this you know to try to reclaim
this kind of Olympian stance is to have
more
beating viewpoints and you know kind of
hope that's in the competition of these
viewpoints the truth will eventually
emerge I would just add I agree with
that i would add one other word
interactivity that somehow mainstream
media has got to be able to talk back
and forth with its audience and and get
an exchange going that is has not been
true in the past is maybe not
sufficiently true now and is crucial to
going forward and getting a kind of
building a kind of confidence for the
longest time it was believed that
younger people you know traditionally
don't read newspapers don't partake of
mainstream news until the notion was
they get a little bit older into their
late 20s or whatever they get married
have a child a mortgage and worry some
more about some of the issues that that
are in the paper and then begin and
become customers and and you know build
the base I'm not certain that's that
model is going to continue and therefore
I think they have to that's when I say
interactivity they have to begin to
communicate more effectively with the
audience and find a way to establish
what they're really what people in the
audience are concerned about and and
address those things and write about
those like hi my name is Oliver I'm
support staff here at MIT um I found it
interesting that the subject of today's
talk was 2004 election and you guys both
spoke very eloquently about the campaign
and what happened after the election but
nothing was really spoken as far as I
could remember about what actually
happens on November second and I
remember feeling very distinctly in two
thousand that my god you know we don't
necessarily have one person one vote in
this country as long as not every vote
counts and that was like a huge
realization to mean I don't think I was
alone in that sort of awakening feeling
and I was paying attention very intently
this time around to find out what the
coverage would be like
of what happens on November second and I
didn't feel that the coverage was really
adequate I'm still have a lot of
questions about the Diebold machines and
about the fact that in many minority
communities he had people waiting on
line four six seven eight nine hours it
seems to me as long as you have that you
don't have legitimate government and I
didn't really feel like there was enough
coverage of that in the media there was
some the election night was interesting
in that the largest news organizations
did not repeat the fiasco of four years
earlier and Miss called the election in
fact they held their fire in the face of
exit polls that were quite faulty based
on a faulty sample and were suggesting
through the afternoon the John Kerry was
going to win and they had that
information as the evening newscast went
on the air and started to bring in
returns after seven and eight pm eastern
and yet they held back they did not make
any faulty projections as to the
coverage of irregularities there was
some but I believe there was a basic
conclusion reached and I don't know if
you disagree with it that the
irregularities to use that word or
abuses were were not enough to change
the outcome that seemed to be the
consensus position that was arrived at
that despite all the problems that you
just cited of long lines and mechanical
breakdowns and other things that in this
case there was enough of a margin that
it wouldn't have made the difference
yeah there was actually a very well
researched I thought piece on salon.com
which is hardly a probe bush publication
to put it mildly which looked at a lot
of those charges and basically said you
know look we really wish it were true
but it doesn't yeah it's just not enough
to change the outcome and again I want
to return to you know what seems to be
my kind of mantra those this evening
which is you know the agenda and
waze's said by the politician i mean if
the kerry campaign had chosen to
challenge the election results that
would have been a huge story but I mean
the kerry campaign decided that there
wasn't enough there to bring a challenge
to the to the to the election results
and hence it did not end up being a huge
story hi my name is christian vicari I'm
a visiting graduate student from the
University of Milan mrs. youngest
brought it up a couple of times so I
wanted to address the issue of the
increasing partisanship in the media and
you know this is not the golden age for
American parties there's a lot of
Independence out there they're supposed
to be the fastest-growing kind of
political population and yet the media
becoming much more partisan now than it
used to be in the 50s and 60s where a
lot of more Americans identified with
the parties the same with young
generations they are largely you know a
political or you know they don't know
yet a lot of them just don't pay much
attention or they'd have not developed a
political attitude yet which is so firm
and yet they don't seem to believe that
there is objectivity and they'd rather
go to some more partisan and you know
ideological media why is that is that a
failure in the you know traditional
institutional media is it and maría way
to garner some new marketplaces for
media that are see their audiences
shrinking what it is from the
perspective of you know journalists hmm
I correct a good first okay um yeah I
think part of the reason may be that the
Rose growing partisanship is that I
think the the people who are less
partisan tend to be kind of more
laid-back apathetic inna less involved
is you do have these populations on both
the kind of fairly extreme left and well
not I don't want to use words like
extreme because that that has all these
negative connotations but you know
basically further to the end you know
further away from the center to both the
left and the right people with you know
really strong opinions and I think
because those people feel more strongly
well you know things I think they're
much more likely to seek out you know
media outlets that essentially you know
support their views media outlets where
they would feel at home politically so I
think that's that really accounts partly
for the polarization that's but I think
you're mixing two things that there is
there's on the one hand there is a
greater polarization in the public
that's clear almost cultural clash in
this country on the other end and on the
other hand there is obvious disaffection
among younger people with mainstream
media I agree with you on that aim the
but they're not the same thing the
polarization this a divided country is
divided on on the issue some of the
issues we've been discussing and it's
come down split almost in the middle and
two elections now you can't get them any
closer than this so it's a it is divided
in in at least the choices it makes for
president and high office but this other
tendency the Catholic referred to which
is which is interesting which is you you
go to the news that supports your views
is is a phenomenon that has certainly
increased in the last 10 to 15 years and
is require some real study I agree that
people for a variety of reasons go to
those outlets that reflect where they
stand I think they're doing so not for
information but for reaffirmation of the
wisdom of their view and sometimes for
entertainment it's a form of
entertainment not you in question how
wonderful it is but I mean you know to
hear people echoing your views on on
controversial issues
I think it's also may be feeling I'm
feeling kind of a part of the community
especially in some of the you know blogs
that have the open comments where people
basically talk to each other and again I
do think that part of the problem is
that it becomes a kind of echo chamber
where you only talk to like-minded
people and then you kind of come in for
a rude surprise when you emerge into the
real world so or come out on the short
end of it all I Yeah Yeah right right
which side do we go to now is it yeah
okay I'm blossom Hogue I work here at
MIT and I also am very active with the
Sierra Club I certainly agree that
carries campaign was not the most
organized that it should have been and
probably I questioned that he was the
right candidate even for the Democratic
Party unfortunately the
environmentalists I think also should
have that charge that they as much time
and effort that they put in to getting
out there and working on campaigns it
didn't make the difference and probably
the religious right was able to bring
out more of the young people and
counteract the environmentalists but the
question is I mean environmental issues
i haven't heard neither one of you speak
of them it was certainly not brought out
in the campaign here we are again we've
not signed the Kyoto Protocol this is a
travesty and yes the campaign and issues
are dictated by the Commission and by
the campaigns but I think the media can
delve and massage and go into other
areas than than just what is being
dictated to be brought to the forefront
and I'd like to have your comments on
that I'm actually curious what you think
whether whether you believe what would
it have taken to arouse the
environmental community more than it was
in this life
last election you have a administration
that had rolled back virtually every
significant piece of environmental
legislation and promised to do more and
yet it did not you're right it did not
become front and central in the campaign
and the voice of those who were alarmed
by that those voices were not as loud or
passionate or paid attention to as one
might expect I'm not you know you say
maybe Kerry wasn't the best candidate
well who was better that's always the
question you have to ask yourself in
that regard but well gore okay all right
well I mean that's that's an N you know
that's a plausible man came either
either one in 2,000 or came very close
to it depending on how you define it and
then an event won the popular vote so
you know you can do where was treated as
kind of a third party in the same in
that way that they they aren't really
brought to the forefront by the media
and the dialogue isn't there and that's
one of the big problems but they have
money they have organization they have
the capacity to participate in the
process and we put a lot of people out
there and in most of the states but I
agree it wasn't enough but blossom your
point really is that the meet your
question really is why did the media not
cover more of the environmental argument
despite what whether or not the
candidates were addressing the question
correct I mean the environmental is
supported carry because of his
environmental background and stance and
yet that never came out anywhere and it
never got to be an issue some halland
I'm not sure how we go about changing
that I think you know part of the
problem I think is that you know
in the selection though as Terrence's
said you know the the Iraq kind of ended
up sucking the air out of everything
else so to speak a lot of other issues
and that I've been treated as secondary
because you know the in a way in many
ways this did end up being an election
about the war and there were I mean I i
guess the public does generally have a
limited the amount of you know issues
that it can pay attention to at the same
time and the in the selection the
environment kind of ended up not being
one of these issues on the front burner
and again I think part of that is this
is the candidates faltan that yeah I
don't remember Carrie making the
environment all that definition his
campaign so actually don't think it was
Iraq I think it was a 911 election well
and the aftermath and how this country
was dealing with that and since see Rock
has very little to do with 911 it was
almost a separate subject but it didn't
but it did push I agree that it did push
terribly important issues like the
environment and others down in the
public attention meter or whatever you
want to call it right I would actually
say that it was it was the Iraq election
on the among Democrats and the 911
election for Republicans because I think
for you know that I think was the real
divide because I think for the for the
Democrats that really was mostly in a
referendum on the on the war in Iraq and
I think for for a lot of Republicans I
think word well not just Republicans but
you know Bush voters who obviously
include a lot of independence and you
know by the way I did I I I think that
the the argument that it was really
about you know moral values as you know
gay marriage and so forth as opposed to
the national security and terrorism and
the war in Iraq that eventually didn't
hold up i think that that was kind of
the initial impression that was created
by some of the
analysis but I think that when you add
up some of the different questions like
you know national security plus it plus
the war in Iraq you know plus some other
related issues I think you do end up
with you know a very different picture
and I I do think that for most of the
electrode it was primarily about those
issues you mean the Massachusetts state
legislature didn't lose it for John
Kerry hahaha I got it wrong oh you know
I I want to take the moderators
prerogative to mention that we have
about 15 16 minutes left so there's time
for questions but also to make a brief
observation this is not a conclusion
that I draw only from our discourse this
afternoon although it has been
reinforced by this but I I fear that the
tendency on maybe both the right and the
left but certainly among among Democrats
and then among those that 50 nearly
fifty percent of the country who feel
that this election was a catastrophic
error that the impulse to blame the
media for what happened is a very strong
one but it may well be that the one
conclusion to draw from what we've
already heard is that the problem is
with the democratic process it isn't the
media that's failing but the democratic
process as it's a structured in the
United States that's failing that there
are not the US there isn't a kind of
European model in which there are a
range of different parties that you can
vote for there isn't a parliamentary
model that would allow for different
sorts of voices to come out and so the
sort of simplifications that Kathy was
describing are inherent in a two-party
system and many of the difficulties that
are being described here are not
functions it seems to me of media
coverage so much as they as they are a
function of the way the process itself
operates i'm good i quickly comment and
that just in terms of the
oversimplification i think one really
underestimated phenomenon is the number
of people who really do feel kind of
politically homeless at the moment
because they feel very alienated by you
know some aspects of both parties
platforms i mean there are a lot of
fiscally conservative you know people
who are you know somewhat hawkish on
foreign policy who at the same time are
just you know appalled by the rise of
the religious right and did those stance
on abortion and gay rights and stem cell
research etc and you know at the same
time that they're also a lot of socially
conservative Democrats who support the
economic program of the Democratic Party
and the foreign policy program but at
the same time feel very alienated on
those social issues so i think there's
there are a lot of people who you know
we usually do end up voting one way or
the other you know or maybe not ah but
who really are kind of being missed by
this by this polarizing discourse where
everybody is kind of packaged into these
neat little boxes labeled red or blue
i'm alexander i'm on staff here at the
Media Lab and I one of the topics that
you've been covering sort of come into
the same ball you know when you talk
about alienation I think that the
candidates just kept adjusting the same
points over and over and over again and
they were so close together that it was
hard to sort of differentiate and yet
each could have made that
differentiation with things that they
had expertise and the environmental is a
huge example both Carrie and Al Gore had
a lot of interest and a lot of
experience and we're very eloquent on
issues of the environment and yet didn't
bring it up and I would question 911 as
as determining that because I don't
think Al Gore brought it up very much
during his campaign when he could have
made it a big a big differentiating
point and Carrie certainly could have to
so I I wonder are they so concerned
about how they're going to be perceived
or how their messages are going to be
picked up either by the media or the
public that they refrain from adjusting
it at all it's better proportion I mean
they do bring it up they do make
speeches about the environment and
challenging their opponents position and
so forth in there covered and
and the debate moves on it's so it's a
matter of but what catches your
attention your memory and I understand
that is that it was barely brought up
well because it was it was drowned out
basically by the other bigger issues or
themes I shouldn't even say bigger just
other issues and themes in the in the
campaign candidates repeat again and
again what they believe are the four or
five or six basic points that they're
trying to get across to the public
rightly or wrongly they believe in
repetition and believe that that's the
way you get it across and so that I
think accounts for the repetitious
nature of much of what they do and say
in advertising in speeches and points
made in the debate and that that's a you
know that's why it all sounds the same
yeah I think also the other factor not
to be you know underestimated is that
you know beyond a certain point the
environmental message you know can be
alienating to a part of the electorate
and then not obviously not the basic
message of Environmental Protection but
if you look at fronts and some of the
things that Al Gore said in the earth in
the balance book he was basically
arguing that we need to radically
restructure our lives in our society and
kind of dramatically scaled down and you
know older consumption for the sake of
the environment and that is a message
that is going to be pretty controversial
so I and I think it's it's something
that can be very easily used by you know
the other side to say that you know the
Democrats want to sacrifice your job to
save the spot Adele and you know that I
think is part of the part of the reason
that it's not maybe that it's not
brought up as much as you would like to
because it's not quite as automatically
a winner
saw as up may at first glance appear to
be so hi I'm Ann Weber I'm down from
Portsmouth New Hampshire and I'm a
writer and I'm actually writing an
article this weekend for a newspaper on
their new media and I'd like to ask a
question that is based on several of
both of your comments mrs. young you had
mentioned that one of the things that
could help media is to offer a greater
diversity of voices and mr. Smith you
had mentioned that for example in the
case is a swift boat controversy one of
the reasons immediate couldn't do a
quick and effective review of these
claims was because of resources given
that would you like to comment on the
impact of media conglomeration on the
coverage of the campaign and on the
continuing coverage of the
administration well it's a single most
striking trend and in the media I mean
in that world of the last 15 years the
largest voices are now held among the
fewest number of owners and the
consolidation continues it's part of the
economic pressures on the industry it's
also the point has been made that say
television news is a victim of its own
success in that it has 60 minutes and
other broadcasts prove that can be
extremely profitable and as they began
to bring in money and as the networks
were acquired by much larger
conglomerates the news division became
simply another profit center another cog
in the larger wheel and was told to
produce the revenues and and do so on
smaller and smaller budgets the budgets
themselves actually increase because of
the increasing cost but percentage on a
percentage basis
they go down I think where you see it as
a problem in political coverage is
staying with the election is not when
not in what you might call the
established opinion press for the
generations we know that the nation is a
liberal magazine we know that national
review is a largely conservative
magazine there's no confusion among the
audience there's no concern that the
problem arises when opinion is inserted
under the guise of objectivity when you
say to your viewers over and over again
that you are fair and balanced when you
are neither that's the problem that's
where the deception arises not the
clearly labeled opinion press yeah well
in terms of conglomeration specifically
I'm actually not sure that you know
ownership yeah that kind of you know
fewer or owners necessarily means more
uniformity of views because you could
have you know more spread out ownership
with you know basically most of the
editors most of the producers most of
the journalists coming from the same
kind of cultural and political
background then I think you would you
know that would give you a certain
amount of uniformity regardless of who
the owners are I think that you won one
problem that i actually do see and it's
it's not really so much conglomeration
as in a lot of cities for instance if
you look at the print media a lot of you
know two three four newspapers cities
what used to be you know in the past two
three four newspaper cities are now
basically one newspaper cities to it the
most so I think the closing of
newspapers which you know the diverse
editorial positions I think is a problem
I mean ownership again the well for
instance I
I wrote for the Boston Globe I used to
write for the Detroit News at one point
in the detroit news this was in the
early no actually late 90s the Detroit
News basically merged its business
operations with the Detroit Free Press I
mean they basically they had that they
have the same the same ownership you're
in the same building yeah they're on the
same building nevertheless you know the
Detroit News is recognizably you know
with a more conservative slant and the
Detroit Free Press is fairly liberal so
you know I I think that owners generally
recognized that you know if it's in
their interest in terms of you know
profit to provide a platform for diverse
views you know they will generally do
that so I don't know that conglomeration
per se is a problem but I do think that
in this regard the rise of the blogs and
you know the rise of the internet based
media really is quite refreshing because
the startup costs are really very low
and it certainly does bring a lot of
different voices into the fold who would
not have been heard before and and I
think that was one of the positive
developments definitely this hi my name
is Rekha Murthy I'm a student with CMS
comparative Media Studies I had a
question by actually decided to drop it
because of a recurring theme that I've
heard and what Cathy was saying that I
find pretty intriguing you said at one
point early on who elected the media as
and then you've kind of continued to say
throughout the course of the evening
that the media doesn't set the agenda
the politicians do for any number of
reasons i find that actually quite
troubling and i would love to hear a
clarification because in from my point
of view being elected that kind of a
statement assumes that the media has to
know its place as an inferior place
beneath politicians who have been
publicly elected it also assumes that
being elected is a complete expression
of the voice of the people it also kind
of implies that the media is
a monolithic party in and of itself and
we all know that that is not the case so
I just want it would love to hear I want
to know if more of your colleagues if
you feel that other people share this
same view of the media's role in
politics and and to hear maybe if if you
have a clarification on your statement
sure well I think that when when the
question is asked why didn't the media
said the agenda I think that does in a
way presume that the media are you know
a fairly monolithic body that would have
the same idea basically of what you know
the agenda is now in terms of should the
media know their place well I certainly
think that you know the media part of
the media's role is to be you know to be
watchdogs and of course you know now we
have we have the blogs functioning as
watchdogs watching the media so you know
it's just kind of getting more and more
complicated with all these different
layers of monitoring and fact-checking
but yeah I think certainly the media
have have a very important role as as
watchdogs in terms of setting the agenda
I mean I don't know that I mean who says
the agenda is a really really
complicated question I think ultimately
you know did in an ideal world of course
the people would set the agenda in terms
of you know what their concerns are but
of course those concerns are you know
largely dictated were at least shaped by
what ends up being reported in the media
so I think there's a very very
complicated and kind of you know often
sometimes symbiotic sometimes
adversarial relationship between the
media the public and the politicians
just wonder like what comment I do think
that in you know in in recent decades
until maybe until maybe the past few
years I do think that there was
something of this medium monomyth which
will
believe that and you know to some extent
still does that part of its role is to
you know not just report the news not
just examine the news but actually sub
the agenda and you know promote certain
you know political values and I and I
think to some extent do if you really
think about it that really does clash
with objectivity though because then I
mean if you're promoting a certain
agenda I it just seems to me that that's
not entirely compatible with being
objective so you know I don't know if
that if that answers your question you
know when you ask the other part of your
question who elected the media of course
no one elects the media the only people
who elect this newspaper or that
broadcaster or whatever are the people
who pay a dollar to buy the new york
times or turn on the television to this
channel versus that they elect who or
which organization to watch to believe
and to return to that's who elects the
media hi I'm see Brophy on teaching
assistant in the literature department
I've got two questions that i think are
interrelated one is at address to mr.
Smith because it's another uncovered
election story why was it apparently
taken for granted that it was ok for the
representative of the Republican Party
who was running to be president of all
the people to only address audiences
that were made up of invited people and
then you know anybody who didn't wasn't
ready to sign a loyalty oath to the
Republican Party was ejected the second
question is we had polls throughout the
period that said they showed up to
approximately forty percent of the
people polled believe that weapons of
mass destruction had been found in Iraq
you know believed all those of
stories about Iraq in the war on terror
being synonymous with each other how
would a responsible major media entity
have developed strategies to reduce that
of disinformation well on the WMD issue
it's really no surprise that in the face
of international inspections of our own
teams going to try to find these weapons
that that the public believed that such
weapons existed and in fact even had
been found and the reason they did is it
was clearly intimated by the
administration and those in favor of the
war and they continued in the face of
the absence of these weapons to say that
that matter was still unresolved and
that there certainly were there was
partial evidence and we'd have to win I
mean so that's where they got the
impression that weapons either were
there or remain to be found because it
was being suggested by not only by the
President the Vice President although he
was a leader in this department but in
those wishing to justify the war and so
that that was the I believe is a partial
explanation for why they a percentage of
the public continues to believe that in
in in the face of all evidence to the
contrary and what was the earlier point
sleeve what can the media do it'll
counter right that perception i think
that was was no the first party the
first ball okay but yeah actually you
haven't answered the question which was
how would the media develop a
responsible strategy to address that
level of incomprehension or whatever and
the first part had to do with why with
who with the with the the weather the
audiences for bush's campaign were self
selected yes oh I'm sorry yeah yeah let
me go to that for a moment in the it's a
it is a not entirely original
technique that this administration has
raised to a level I have never heard of
the president travels in a bubble that
is not just security he goes to events
where tickets are issued and only to the
Republican faithful and only even
nowadays on this little campaign on
social security to those who agree with
him on social security and then up on
the stage next to him since mrs.
so-and-so who's going is convinced that
this is a terrific idea and will
interact with him it's it's part of a
strategy of building support you want to
have coverage of these events or SATs as
they may be in which there appears to be
support look at that hall full of people
they're all applauding must be a great
idea and so it's incredibly simplistic
it's insulting to the intelligence of
the larger audience but it is a rather
tracking true political technique in it
it's used generally during campaigns now
it's being used generally as a as a mo
for presidential events certainly as a
result the president never hears any
criticism I am convinced the reason that
george w bush was so off his game in the
first debate when john kerry came out
very aggressively going after him
choosing him of lying and distorting and
so forth you know presidents don't hear
that he'd gone for years of constant
applause ringing in his ear and so they
just don't hear it and he was clearly
taken aback well he found his feet in
the second and third debates but but it
was it was very striking to me in the
first I'm sorry I asked her campus as to
how the media is supposed to persuade
the public that black is black and not
white in the face of this kind of
thing I don't know what you can do but
keep reporting it and and hope that you
get through well you could imagine an
responsible Network refusing to cover a
staged event that was that was a circus
they do they mean look they go out and
they cover the first two or three of
those and and then the coverage drops
off sharply I want to thank the audience
and thank the speakers
you